mario maneja 1500 kilómetros cada mes
cuál de las siguientes gráficas
representa correctamente el total de
kilómetros recorridos por mario en un
período de seis meses bueno pues vamos a
ver las gráficas en esta de acá en la
gráfica a al primer medios mario ha
recorrido 1.500 para el segundo mes ya
lleva 3.000 otros 1500 entonces todo va
muy bien y al tercer mes pues llega como
a 4500 que son otros 1500 más entonces
está de aquí se ve muy bien déjame
ponerla en un círculo y vamos a checar
si las otras no son mejores vamos a la
cee enlace a ver el primer mes recorrió
muy poquito como 250 kilómetros más o
menos eso no es lo que queremos porque
ponen está a pues porque al mes 6
recorrió 1500 pero eso no queremos
verdad nosotros queremos que recordar
1500 kilómetros cada mes cada mes sí
entonces esa no es vamos a ver esta de
acá tenemos que desde el principio lleva
1.500 kilómetros recorridos
y permanece ahí en realidad aquí ya no
recorre kilómetros extra entonces está
ya acá tampoco sería y en esta de acá al
primer mes recorre 9000 kilómetros que
no es para nada lo que queremos sale
bueno entonces la respuesta sería y
vamos al problema 24 en el problema 24
nos dicen la temperatura en la cima de
una montaña fue de 7 grados fahrenheit a
las 6 pm a las 8 pm la temperatura bajó
a 0 grados fahrenheit si la temperatura
siguió bajando aproximadamente en la
misma razón cuál es el mejor estimado
para la temperatura de las 11pm pues a
lo mejor convenga a empezar calculando
la razón en la cual baja la temperatura
déjame pasar estos datos para acá a ver
a las 6 pm la temperatura fue de 7
grados fahrenheit luego a las 8 pm dos
horas después
la temperatura bajó a 0 grados
fahrenheit vamos a calcular la razón
pasaron dos horas y lo que sucedió con
la temperatura es que bajó siete grados
fahrenheit entonces la razón de cambio
fue bajar siete grados fahrenheit entre
un periodo de dos horas y esto de aquí
cuando es haber menos siete entre dos es
menos 3.5
y las unidades serían grados fahrenheit
por hora grados fahrenheit por hora muy
bien bueno esta de acá sería la razón de
cambio lo que ahora tenemos que hacer es
ver cuánto tiempo más pasó y de las 8 pm
a las 11 pm a las 11 pm fueron otras 3
horas de modo que para estimar la
temperatura a las 11 pm tenemos que
multiplicar 3 horas por menos 3.5 grados
fahrenheit por hora tenemos que hacer
tres horas por
- 3.5 grados fahrenheit por hora las
unidades quedan así horas se cancelan
con horas y por lo tanto quedan grados
fahrenheit y hay que hacer 3 x menos 3.5
haber menos 3.5 x 3 3 x 5 es 15 llevamos
13 x 39 y una que llevamos 10 hay que
recorrer el punto decimal un lugar y
poner este signo menos entonces nos
quedaría que la temperatura aproximada
es menos 10.5 grados fahrenheit y lo que
más se parece a esto de aquí es menos 10
grados fahrenheit la respuesta sería c
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 25 en
el problema 25 nos dice que braulio
compró un compró una paleta de 6 pesos y
varios chicles que costaron 60 centavos
cada uno y en total pagó 13 pesos con 20
centavos cuantos chicles comprobar audio
bueno pues otra forma de ver a estos 13
pesos con 20 centavos son como los 6
pesos de la paleta más lo que cuesta
cada chicle 0.60 multiplicado por la
cantidad de chicles que no sabemos
cuánto es así que déjame ponerle ese si
supiéramos que la cantidad de chicles es
20 pues lo que gasto sería 6 pesos más
0.6 de cada chicle por 20 porque son 20
chicles salen pero lo que sabemos es que
esto de aquí es igual a 13 pesos con 20
centavos y de aquí necesitamos despejar
se déjame hacerlo lo primero que voy a
hacer es restar 6 de ambos lados
-6 aquí -6 acá eso es para que este 6 se
cancele con este menos 6 y nos quede que
0.6 c es igual a 13.20 menos 6 13 6 7
entonces 0.6 es igual a 7.20 y ahora
tenemos que dividir entre 0.6 entre 0.6
para que aquí se cancele y del otro lado
hago lo mismo entre 0.6 entonces nos
queda que sé la cantidad de chicles es
7.20 dividido entre 0.6 bueno pues vamos
a hacer esta división por acá vamos a
hacer una división de casita 7.20
dividido entre 0.6 dividir entre
decimales puede ser un producto un poco
truculento un poco truculento es
truculento hasta decirlo vaya jaja bueno
pero lo que hay que hacer es recorrer el
punto decimal en lo que está afuera de
este punto decimal lo recorremos a la
derecha hasta que se vuelva un entero
aquí lo recorrimos un lugar
por lo tanto aquí adentro también
tenemos que recorrerlo un lugar de modo
que esta fracción es lo mismo que 72
entre 6 sale otra forma de pensarlo
y es que multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por 10 bueno vamos a hacer
la división 6 caben 7 una vez 1 por 6 3
6 7 6 es uno baja el 26 cabe dos veces
en 12 2 veces 2 por 6 3 12 12 12 0 y por
lo tanto la respuesta sería 12 la
respuesta sería si la mira hasta puedo
ponerle a 15 es igual a 12 la cantidad
de chicles bueno vamos al problema 26
nos preguntan cuánto es 35 al cuadrado
entre 4 - x 1 cuando x es igual a 7
bueno vamos a sustituir x igual a 7 aquí
déjame copiar la expresión nos quedaría
3 + este 5 al cuadrado me conviene
ponerlo como 25 dividido entre 4 hay
entendido que lo que quieren que hagamos
es entender un poco el orden de las
operaciones entonces déjame déjame poner
aquí como y el orden primero van
paréntesis
paréntesis luego va exponencia ción
luego va a multiplicación y división y
si hay empate es de izquierda a derecha
luego sería suma y resta suma y resta y
nada más verdad suma y resta entonces
primero hacemos este paréntesis 3
+ 5 al cuadrado este 5 al cuadrado está
dentro del paréntesis así que hay que
hacerlo primero nos queda 25 3 más 25 es
estoy acá sería 28 luego hay que dividir
entre 4 y hay que restar lo de este
paréntesis cuando x es igual a 7 nos
queda 77 1 que es 8 entonces nos
quedaría 28 28 entre 4 ya eso hay que
restarle 8 primero hay que hacer la
división ha sido el orden de las
operaciones 28 entre 4 es 77 menos 8 es
igual a menos 1 la respuesta es b
muy bien vamos al problema 27 problema
27 nos pregunta cuál es la ecuación de
la gráfica que se muestra a continuación
todas estas están en la forma mx más b
recuerda que eso es poner es igual a mx
+ b donde m es la pendiente y b es donde
interfecta al eje g y la pendiente para
calcular la pendiente lo que tenemos que
hacer es ver cuánto aumentamos cuanto
aumentamos dividido entre cuanto
recorrimos vale o bien el cambio en g
entre el cambio en x m la pendiente es
igual al cambio
dividido entre el cambio en x y aquí
tenemos que el cambio en que fue 1 el
cambio en x fue 1 entonces m es igual a
1 pero eso no nos dice gran cosa porque
en todas estas tenemos que la pendiente
es igual a 1 entonces vamos a tener que
hacer algo más vamos a encontrar la
intersección con el eje y y eso está
aquí verdad está en e igual a 3 en el
punto 0,3 y por lo tanto la ecuación
sería h
x + 3 la respuesta sería c muy bien
y listo terminamos con los problemas de
esta página